three of lizzo's former dancers have
accused the singer of sexual harassment
and creating a hostile work environment
in a lawsuit filed Tuesday number one
what a mistake
to hire 10 lizos this idea that she's
going to create a community of fat lizos
that are all going to get along and love
each other
that they're not going to turn around
and go why is this [__] the lead when
they all look like her here's what she
should do lizzo should get super thin
it's now time to throw fat people under
the bus the time for fat is over now
you've made enough money off the pigs
it's time to leave the barn God I could
I could do these I could never stop with
these I could do these for hours it's
time to leave the barn okay
here's what you have to do
you have to get hot you have to write a
book about Wellness
you have to go you have to denounce the
fats thank you